but then Connor hasn't fought in 500
days he's not stripped yeah exactly
Connors not stripped yet haha hasn't
fought in more than 500 days MMA last
time he fought was Eddie Alvarez does
his last MMA fight I was a long time ago
man yeah as a long time ago and then he
hasn't been stripped so imagine being a
lightweight just sitting around waiting
well he's on boxing TV having a boxing
match
Floyd Mayweather he doesn't even get
stripped of his title doesn't defend it
makes 100 million bucks feel like when
you fighting again I was like who
[ __ ] knows it would be a lot of [ __ ]
but be a lot clearer as what to do in
the situation if Connor would have just
fought like a regular lightweight
champion there wouldn't be this this
interim confusion it's so good for Conor
though all that just makes it bigger and
bigger it's like they even changed the
rules for him you know I mean like think
about that for him like it just makes
him bigger he has had fun 508th who
[ __ ] cares he's just rolling around
in a bathtub full of hundred bills every
day just dive it in there and swimmin he
can do whatever the [ __ ] he wants yeah
did you see that documentary on that
Flint oh I didn't yeah he knew he was
gonna be a champion back in the day it
starts when he he has just one tattoo
the one down one down his back that's it
none of the neck tattoos or anything and
he already knew he knew he just had like
dynamite in his hands yeah crushing
people on the local local scene crushing
them yeah one shots boom yeah I saw him
fight in 2013 I think somewhere around
there in his first chance at the UFC I
wouldn't even know and if I didn't see
this document it's hard to keep track of
everything but wasn't Sweden it was a
Swedish show it was like last-minute
replacement they brought a man and he
fought what was his name black guy [ __ ]
I forget his name good guy real good guy
and he'd let him up and that was I
damned after that one fight like there's
there's footage of him and Dana and like
Dana was already here any nude he goes
man I guess the hype was real Jesus my
favourite fights with him
are the two fights with Nate Diaz though
you know why because those the fights we
couldn't put someone away just crack him
and put him away so you had to see him
fight yeah he had a fight
yeah and it's a totally different game
like if you see what he did to Eddie
Alvarez that was a totally different
kind of fight because he's stung Eddie
early had him hurt and he was his he
owned him and then he [ __ ] him up and
stopped him that was a beating what
round was that it was a second saying
was a second he barely made it out of
the first right yeah I barely made it I
mean he got [ __ ] up from the get-go
and Connor just had his number it's way
faster way quicker in like covering
distance just just like laser beams at
night and I don't think Eddie fought
right I think Eddie was a little bit too
caught up in the moment this is a big
hype of the fight and the fight Conor
McGregor and he just got [ __ ] up he
kind of had his hands behind his back
and standing right in front of him
checking them and then popping him in
the face like that was ugly so that you
know like what year was that
that's five hundred those five hundred
days ago like that's that that kind of
fight is a great fight for Conor but
that's all hammer when he fought Nate he
had to be the nail yeah there are a lot
of that yeah the whole [ __ ] second
round of the first fight when Nate got
him down was the second round submission
right wasn't it I don't know when he
submitted him but Nate's submit him in
the second round what are you looking at
me funny woman
you got something these foot pull up
more than I do with my deck
that's what Conor said these fools pull
out more than I do with my dick I like
how he had specified with he must have
only pulled out four times max that's
not that great
the fights with Nate were fights you
know he had a dig deep and he lost the
first one he got beat up he got taken
down he got his back taken he got choked
he tapped I mean he [ __ ] lost that
fight and then the second fight he drops
Nate but he can't put Nate away Nate
gets back up they're going after it
there's [ __ ] times where he's got to
stand and walk away he's got to walk
away because he's too tired he can't
engage right now ok so he walked away a
couple times in those exchanges those
were dig dig fights what's that buddy
round two yeah yeah yeah ok submission
rear naked choke four minutes of 12
seconds of the round 2 yeah he beat him
down warm down
and then stopped him that's and the
fight that Conard one could that have
gone either Yeah right there was
arguments right that's very close fight
and very close fight I think in the new
rules Conor probably would have won
because